cardinals have a good one on the mound
themselves
and tonight the 52nd career
appearance 43rd start against the cubs
that's the most in those categories in
the long
rich history of adam wainwright and one
of the things i i
wanted to look at and and i should have
done it but i didn't get to it but by
feel
it seems as if adam wainwright pitches
after losses a lot
it sure does because it seems like every
time he's on the mound we say you know
what
it's time for adam wainwright to change
the momentum and boy there's no more
momentum going the cubs way than what we
experienced in the ninth inning so
wainwright again has that job wainwright
looks in from the stretch working on
wilson contreras
lifted in the air into deep left center
back at the wall he's got it oh
what a catch harrison better he robbed
him
and the fans are loving it
i'm not sure who's loving it more the
fans harrison bader or adam wainwright
i mean everybody loving it here except
contreras
boehner back up against the wall and i
think that was over the wall
the high lead and how about him leaping
with two hands
about the throwback in the infield
tremendous play
harrison bader professor he'll sink it
outstanding change-up of course he'll
elevate a four-seam fastball from time
to time
and also mix in some curveballs david
ross talking in the pregame about his
evolution
as a pitcher and you see good evidence
there is he really changed his mix a
little bit 12-4 record 3.65
era last 12 starts 10-0 for the 2.48
one down and the batter paul goldsmith
goldie rips it out to left going back
over he's headed off the wall paul
goldschmidt
a 16-game hitting streak well that ball
goldschmidt hit looked like it had an
afterburner on it by the time it got to
the outfield it soared
over ian happ's head and went banging
off the wall rolling toward the infield
and goldschmidt went in standing at
second
active players right now goldschmidt
third in ops
batting average slugging fourth and on
base
he has had their number scoreless game
third inning one away here's rafael
ortega now this might be a good chance
for horner to run he lines a base hit to
right toward the line
this ball is going to go all the way to
the wall it bounces off the wall
horner racing around third heading home
he will score
ortega goes to third with a triple cubs
lead one to nothing
rafael ortega pulling a line drive
over goldsmith's head it got all the way
to the wall
horner scores it's a three-base hit for
rafael ortega
and i really think part of that
at bat for ortega in getting a pitch to
really hit
horner was in the back of wayne wright's
mind because wainwright
he does not slide step very often but he
just slides up there in the first pitch
harrison bader leads off the bottom of
inning number three that one is lined to
the base hit
out of the left center better go get it
vader sprinting for second here's the
throw
[Applause]
great job by ian hat i think he had a
pretty good idea that bader might try
that
and half was wise to it through a strike
to second base
dylan carlson grounded out on the only
pitch he saw
in the first inning here's a line drive
backhanded by horner jump throw to rizzo
backhanded on the short hop in time
good play nico running into shallow
right center made a
jump throw to rizzo a one hop throw
anthony backhanding the ball
on one short hop good play by both men
score it four to three and the cardinals
go one
two three we go to inning number four
two away here in the fifth the cardinals
have men at second
and third and dylan carlson do up goal
strict three
hendricks gets out of the jam carlson
does not like the call
by the home plate umpire jeff nelson but
it's not going to change things
the cardinals leave men at second and
third
mike schilt the cardinal manager has
been thrown out of the game by the crew
chief and home plate umpire jeff
nelson so the cardinals will have an
interim manager for the remaining
four innings of this ball game it's an
rbi spot with a man at third and one
down
javier baez has struck out and popped
out
ground ball left side
and it stays one nothing on a terrific
play by nolan aronado
all instinct for nolan arenado
everything had to be done in fast motion
no
time to think about it does he have time
to get the runner at
at the plate on the backhand can he make
the throw all in one motion
he's got to miss the runner he's got to
throw over his
left shoulder he's going to his right he
almost has to hit a little fade like a
golfer does
around the tree and it goes right on the
money to yadier molina that is a
big time gold glove play
that is a big run at second base the
cubs
lead one to nothing one away and horner
is the key man in the inning
and a diving stop are not o from his
oh he's done it again he
has done it again nolan oronato
with a diving stop to his left and takes
a hit away
it's fun to watch the fan reactions to
the plays of arenado
almost disbelief that he could do some
of the things that he does
and this is saving a run de young leads
at second
vader two for two with a pair of
face singles the game is tied piano will
score
and vader three for three and we're tied
at
one harrison vader
carrera hit number 250 and a big one for
saint louis and he picks up tommy edmond
who wasn't able to get the bunt down but
not necessary harrison boehner drives
the baseball
as he's done so often lately
and has the speed to get the second base
no problem to young scoring
and bader does what he always does
strikes a pose
carlson to turn around and bat
right-handed he was hitless in three
at-bats against hendricks
will score carlsen to second
redbirds on top it's 2-1
dylan carlson a big hit
in a key situation and a little
redemption for him
over the head of half drives in the go
ahead run and how does
adam wainwright feel about it
loving it so that's gives the cubs a
chance one big swing of the bat now and
cubs could take the lead
drilled out towards right center field
carlson
they're not gonna get it pointer racing
towards third
heading to the plate sogar delivers and
we
are tied a run scoring double
into right center the ball game is tied
two to two the ball game is on the line
kimbrella face goldschmidt
your basic power against power veteran
against veteran matchup ground ball to
short
baez has it throws to first beginning
over
kimbrell gets a very big out shirinos at
the plate with half at second
and wisdom at first swinging a fly ball
to center deep back goes bader he's got
to play
makes the catch but the cubs do not
score
first and second nobody out against
kimbrell yadi has gone three for ten
with a homer
molina with a drive and a deep break it
is
down the cardinals will win it
goldie scores yani delivers against
kimbrough
the final in ten three two